I pride myself on being impartial when
I'm debating things right I can do this
on camera Steve I got a double slot
let's go let's talk about Queen so
what's the thing you were saying why the
debate so seven nation army is a classic
and there's no song in the entire world
that people in stadiums will chant the
melody of a song like people don't go
dad like that's not a thing I understand
but I think you're also comparing the
wrong Queen song it should be we will
rock you or we are the champions we all
we are the channels that's finds got to
song okay that's fine that's a different
debate but we've been debating under
pressure and you're an under pressure
and proponent I listen under pressure
and it has had such so much greater of a
cultural impact it's over history people
still know that song it's it's Saturday
night means tween and David Chloe are
the song whatever I think that's
actually personal preference on that
song I think listen is a great song yeah
great song but I would say that Queen
has a number of iconic stadium songs
that have been that the whole world I
mean we are the champions
yeah find that ones that one that's a
close contender even crawling out wanted
to go away together you can't beat that
no no Jack wait well I'm sure I'm glad
that Jack White has a catchy riffs right
so basically this is the way it was on
set the whole time what I will say so I
watched your first two episodes last
night and they are really really well
done and the thing about it is that and
I think maybe people don't realize so
explain the fact that the show takes
place at the high school where the movie
exists like explain that part of it so
the show takes place at the high school
where the movie was shot and we're high
school students who are putting on a
production of the movie High School
Musical so yeah it's very meta very
layered and yeah through that there's a
bunch of twists and turns obviously but
um it's kind of cool where we kind of
pay tribute because obviously if we're
putting on a production of a ski musical
you're gonna be singing some of the
songs from the original but with the
all-new cast and some original songs
it's it's it's own thing
entirely so it's pretty cool one of the
things about this is that your
characters are trying to get into the
musical but you're also in real life you
were trying to get into the series do
you know what I mean yes it's very so
I'm curious what was it like going after
this series and maybe the auditioning
process yeah the audition process is
really great actually and sometimes
audition processes aren't really but um
I think on my first audition I met Josh
and we sang this cover of Bruno Mars
just count on me and having that added
component of music and the audition just
made it absolutely magical and I think
from then on we knew that High School
Musical whether or not I was gonna be a
part of it at the time was really
magical yeah it was the start of
something new it was actually really
funny that you say that what am I the
big audition scene that I had was my
character's audition scene in the show
so my characters nervous and so when I
was nervous for the audition it
completely translated because I'm like
doing this like monologue that Ricky's
doing in the show as Joshua in the
audition room so many layers hahaha I
hate spinning but yeah so that might
help they didn't have to get in
character I just had to be nervous and
then the rest kind of worked itself out
so it's kind of cool it's what's crazy
is you the show has not premiered yet
but I believe you got renewed already
yeah season two yeah how early on did
you know that and how much do you know
about what's gonna happen in season two
we found yes yes and we have absolutely
no idea what is happening with season
two we completely trust our showrunner
amazing creator Tim federally and
whatever he's got up his sleeve we're
gonna put our full trust in so yeah but
we're just really excited to go back to
Salt Lake City and make some more magic
with the people that we love do you know
when you actually start filming sometime
next year yeah yeah sure it's crazy
though I mean it's congratulations on
that thank you